help me out here why is this such a big
deal
this uh that tournament in particular is
such a big deal because it's the
single most uh the single biggest
prize awarded at an esports event ever
with the top prize being
in the solos so a single person could
win three million dollars
which happened yesterday right and i
gather
40 million players try to qualify
for that presumably that was all online
but tried to qualify for this thing in
new york
yeah so the unique thing about the
fortnite world cup was that literally
anyone could enter as long as you were
good enough and you could perform
you can you qualified just from the
comfort of your own home and then
eventually
earn your way to new york to play in
that huge stadium right and just tell us
about this
this game particularly what what's the
idea of it what what do you have to do
so the idea is a hundred people drop
into a map that stays the same
mostly throughout the season and then
you just have to be the last man
standing everyone starts with zero so no
materials which you can build with to
protect yourself or just to kind of uh
create a base somewhere in the uh in the
map
and then you collect guns you collect
shields so
you start from nothing and hopefully end
up the last man standing
right so you're a big star at this and i
mean jaden could well become one i guess
now but what are the skills that he
and you need to be really good at this
i mean my stuff is more video based his
is like pure skill based so
lots of practice great reactions i'm
sure his are much quicker than mine
being
uh over 11 years younger than me which
is crazy
um you need to just yeah lots of
practice make sure you've got your
mechanical skills down and then you're
you're set yeah and is it right though
dan i mean that a 15 year old wins
this sort of money or is it just an
inevitable consequence
of the popularity of this thing
i think the the average age of the
competitors over the two tournaments so
the duos and the solos was 16
so yeah it was inevitable that someone
young
was going to win i was shocked actually
when they said
the average age of the competitors
because i don't think there's another
tournament
where you can enter that young i might
be wrong but yeah there was 14
year olds 15 year olds with incredible
skills they'd obviously put a lot of
time into the game
and winning big money too yeah and i
mean i can see parents go oh my god
you know my son or daughter going to see
this and see that you can win money and
they're going to spend even more time
um you know of this lark and i mean what
would you say
to parents who are worried that you know
their
youngsters and they are young are
spending so much time doing this
i mean i think everything is good in
moderation i'm sure these guys spend a
lot of time
playing the game probably into double
digits of hours in the days but they're
also spending time
probably streaming their um streaming
their progress as well so they'll
probably earn an income from that at the
same time so it's a little bit easier
for them to
uh to do it full time i guess but i
think yeah everything in moderation if
you're if your child is enjoying
something in the video game space
whether it's videos or
all the games themselves then uh my
piece of advice is always to explore it
with them
see what they're doing what their goals
are and
nowadays with the internet as well it's
a lot more social which is great
yeah i mean but is is there a danger of
addiction here i mean
you you've sort of been obviously doing
it for years i mean
is there an addiction problem here
i mean i'm sure you can get addicted to
anything get addicted to football
uh reading anything that you spend lots
of time in but i think it's more
of people enjoying themselves maybe not
to be the next person to win the three
million but just to play games with
their friends because you can now
play in uh squads of four squads of two
and even by yourself you can be in a
chat with your friends so i don't think
it's
i think it's too much of a problem right
and i mean someone like jaden now
you're saying he's you know a lot
younger than you he's 15.
what will his career path be now i mean
will this be a one-off is it likely or
is he obviously very very good and now
he's could be looking at
you know serious riches i mean
to even qualify for that event like you
said there were 40 million people to be
the number one or number two uh duo in
the world is crazy so he's got
a lot of publicity from that so like
esports organizations could be hitting
him up
his streams his social medias anything
will just be
multiplied tenfold i'm sure he's got a
great career ahead of him
and he's only started at 15 which is
crazy right and i say you're a few years
younger
you've made your fortune already have
you
yeah yeah but i'm still i'm still i'm
still working at it but starting at 15
that's way younger than when i started
so uh good luck to him i hope he does
really well